checked gypped it check it out
sweet what's old ah not much it's been a
bit yeah we missed a week I was
launching a show over at twitch fresh
dot um yeah I'm just take first doc
working a couple huge not more big
projects yeah we got going on what
but the biggest project of them all evil
is kaneen e resident Canadian I saw that
caught on on Twitter and I don't like I
wonder if I should buy stuff how much
money do I have $19,000 I don't know
what to upgrade I'm terrible at this
I like it went better when you like pay
attention to what I'm doing and what I'm
doing wrong have you a lot of treasure
sheets so um more money actually I think
all right cool yeah I do have a lot of
treasures I have new venom fangs
I'll sell those and I'm a low on
ammunition
I saw that stupid egg the run nobody
asked for yep
I'm just selling these pears do we want
these oh damn that piercing too a lot of
money I separated my handgun
no I'm doing all right sweet I might
just save my money like we're not dying
so I don't really see the like I'm not
really motivated yeah to do anything the
mail a vest is nice yeah then I can like
die less maybe okay yeah you need that
all right I'm good whatever you are but
you've been saving me I need to buy
anything else I've H&K they're good okay
there I am another Magnum last time I'm
gonna do it
I've got a red mine all right I'm worth
it I'm ready whenever you are
how do I give it to myself sorry what
I'd like give what to yourself you still
have a couple chairs the proximity vest
turned up by a hail a vest whatever
uh did you I thought I did I guess I
didn't obviously I don't know how this
works
yeah you saw proximity bomb and combined
it with us uh yeah by her in the middle
what did i buy just then it's first aid
no I mean nothing else is in your
inventory well where is it then I don't
think you bought anything I think you
might've just knockin you did buy to
melee vests oh my god do you want long I
don't know if you can give me one it's
lost $9,000 well this is going well
wait can you give it to me Holly you can
I use wasted ten thousand gold no I need
some whiskey we're drinking Jameson cuz
it's been that kind of week already it's
been that kind of week I got my second
watch this last time I think I think we
might have watched it off the recording
maybe no wait this is when I was like
let's keep going and you were like no
we're leaving cuz I have [ __ ] to do did
it I was like let's keep going
did I have to do that thing finally
nothing no I just didn't work bunch of
hot nothing yeah I remember that guy
Josh Josh
it's wash you're alive
are you okay he's alright shave us a
hottie how did you get here soz Josh the
port and didn't well he's already I
ended the pier and he's flexing boobie
he's like his head's a bit too small for
his body or something [ __ ] his body's
too big for his head yes now why did you
never treat I mean we are no match for
them I've got unfinished business the
hard drive containing data on the Bo W
experiment had a picture inside the
picture was of Chris's friend a friend
I'm not leaving until I catch herbing
and find out what the hell's going on
here
how inconvenient chapter later graviton
John we're here what score did this get
on average good question
curious I got Metacritic yeah like like
was it reviewed moderately you know yeah
I think so I'll look it up later
oh I'm severely injured
stomp clap stomp stomp clap
but in hell you I think I should heal I
don't even think I can take one hit
right now yeah I don't wanna waste mine
actually I got it oh we got the deck job
oh I got piercing now it's so soon
looking multiple people oh I got both of
them that was I got it I got it I got it
I got it
yeah great everybody I can get you on I
got one spray my face all right we're
good I just playing call of duty zombies
that dlc with like eight of the maps
those are fun I love I like especially
when they get really complex actually
like those are really fun I think only
coming through that window it uh yeah
I'm gonna let them come through that way
we can get the stuff yeah hobbies sit
down
behind you oh wait soon I kind of miss
it vodka she misses you too
sorry I missed
good double do we get double melee
points for that or what
oh gosh behind you oh thank you
damn I say we see if you can get any
items we're going on top
Oh big dude um let's go then oh [ __ ] you
get me okay oh I'm gonna die good you
know I cannot go hi there a button to
press yeah press circle no no no yeah
they go oh I wasn't oh I'm on like to
help
like all right come here commit right we
got a checkpoint I've got a red and
green we can use but always a loophole
that's a song shotgun ammo
[Music]
uh-oh you got her
put a cross on your mouth well he got
stuff to thank you Ellenberger today yep
thank is Sam some sheet metal Mary what
are you hmm
I just want to die I'm having fun with
us this handgun ammo over here with you
oh [ __ ] you are like what do I what's my
I've got another agree with Hickory
sorry it's me I have to admit I wasn't
disputing that um good out see ya I like
I would say there's a lot of fun
elements to the game like I enjoy maybe
it's just because I've been watching you
play four games up until now like I wish
I was a little better yeah but well we
also we haven't been like marathons game
like we did like before like four we got
we took us a while but we was over the
course of a few I'd like to this right
um
damnit you took that ammo I can give the
other shotgun
I can give the if you want yeah I need
to give you something then because I'm
like full can I get rid of it or here is
I can't I'm full like if I give you
something then I can do it let's worry
about that okay this is chainsaw do you
saw I didn't I wasn't really chainsaw
I got top I'm gonna cover you from there
um wait what am i doing hanging around
him I'll jump down when I need to okay
they're coming this way
I don't see how we'll say you come from
anywhere else you might be right um
chainsaw dude right here well can I do
anything to help you I do you want
[ __ ] I'm an idiot right now just
shooting this guy he's new already damn
we did it boys we could kill him for the
reward what kind of reward is it [ __ ]
him up
Oh
I got drunker need no use wasting a ton
of that on
oh I'm so sorry
feel like here here come here I'll okay
no don't worry about it
oh my god I don't think he's allowed to
die do you check his pulse you're
pounding whiskey every time something
goes wrong I was getting um shotgun ammo
when he died I'm gonna need you to heal
me again sorry this is your fault
no come here come here come here come
here cuz you should have combined them
you didn't come bin share you're right
for that chuckles okay
go go
stoppies well let me stop
ah all right there's a proximity bomb
over here do you want it sure
can you pick it up and give it to me
some over here like util I have this um
their legs off budget okay so I have
this um vest that takes up a slot and
then I have another vest if you don't
like the best that I have but the
proximity vine mines probably only four
yeah but over here if I change I just
really want the reward of us where did
you find me did someone drop that I got
a sound area before put that mind down
when the chance I do you come just put
it like up here on this raised platform
once you get there okay
do you like half as health or something
maybe I'll stay up here cuz there's
nothing that hurts him from down there
yeah
[Music]
Kuzma machine gun a low down here if you
want it I don't know how much you care
about that right now a little bit I
don't know if I can
oh wait no yeah I just got mine up there
I did just like you told you
like I like the frenzied nature of it
and I like playing with you like this is
fun like we were talking about playing
this one weekend and just like drinking
a lot like that sounds really fun I
think my reservation just comes from the
fact that like I just shot him four
times of rifle so I'm not ignoring him
no you hear me
get down watch me step back in the mind
you're right next to it you're yeah ah
[ __ ] did it oh yeah
did I do that no that's
sweet all right get ready drops going
really well
yep you see that much better yeah they
just fall backward worth killing these
dudes me debatable Oh should have people
down here with Josh again
oh let's help him or was he just
shooting at nothing I guess
oh no [ __ ] they did drops off a bareback
its shotgun shells go I'll protect I'll
protect our friends yeah he's like
shooting them and their AI is not smart
enough to know what to do
climb [ __ ] it all this [ __ ] just took
the ladder and climb
I wonder how much go through the door
amaura mr. Vaughn am assuming no yes
square some of that whiskey and my wife
you okay
yeah I think so what down I'm okay it
looks like her Venus trying to rule uh
bartender your most talking before it is
too late I'll try to find this the way
out of here
alright we'll go after Irving good okay
now there's a taco bed that is probably
where he's going to make his break copy
that and Ja eighty-three men you're the
dog head based on ninety-one critics
than eighty three not bad let's hurry
okay
they should make a whiskey coffee
didn't they I don't know I'm just
drinking whiskey and then sometimes I'm
drinking coffee and I thought it's
called my yeah just put whiskey and your
coffee
Irish coughing secret [ __ ] on the other
side handgun ammo do you want this yeah
I can't jump they're even supposed to be
go I see okay ghost yeah you ready
Java Java hurry come on come on
nope shava shava
fathers [ __ ]
what is that see
are we going on a ship we going on a
boat yeah I've actually really wanted a
change of scenery we just weren't a
swamp
none of these are like that much
different there will be a change well
there will be it kind of went from like
swamp to military base really fast but
it's all been dingy and not I don't know
I guess I don't know what I wanted like
did I want it to like get really
saturated nice like not really there he
is
I was looking for supplies and you
triggered the cutscene we're next to
each other liner
he's a fast boat what my father smiling
used to yeah
Jewish dude from Brooklyn
wait okay I can't believe you didn't
wait I hate that
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm already almost there
uh no mine brought me over to you wait
Han what's through here yep
ooh a gym
huh okay go go go
I [ __ ] up good alright boom go go come
on [ __ ] I did a bad job okay we should
hurry up more okay
[Music]
actually mimics alarm we both have to be
there or if I can grab this [ __ ] what if
he's like ah I need your help
dogs oh [ __ ]
trip mine trip mine and dogs trip mine
and dogs fat guy [ __ ] alright I
didn't hope I see weed mean yeah I wish
I would have paid attention
saved you with a shotgun above your head
oh hang on how do you get you
to get on this boat
many looks at the camera and he's like
did i do man watch me sleep her going
yeah I was a timely Merkel joke
try self
say something no wow
[Music]
sweet i routed more enemies than you I
guess you have to clear 54 the s my
accuracy was all right
why did I quit did it save yep good
doing was wrong me how much whiskey have
you drank
it's just tired yeah nobody look at my
friends just passed me I found blur
everything out
well not you haven't done any post work
on any of these videos I do think we
should show your your screen one of
these days they can see I don't like
desensitize people those things you see
how it someone that's good oh it's done
all right let's try this again
wait let me sell some [ __ ] you have 60
seconds okay you have 53 seconds done
you haven't even no time we started this
like half an hour ago seven okay
yeah in case you guys forgot I come here
after I work at twitch and we just kind
of finished these up because I want to
play all the Knievel's every Resident
Evil is the goal starting with the
numbered series but at some point we're
going to do a churn because we are so
far behind we wanted to finish all these
before Ezra 7 came out 3 months ago
too bad like we're not too far behind
I'm on
the show has become something else just
something new started as a guide thing
god oh god he's got they're already
throwing
shot you
oof this is hard to me to get the right
vote and you get the left boat sure stop
shaking I can't up heads up ahead of us
ahead of us
never mind got it oh good job another
one everybody got it good job another
one no okay good job
oh I guess we did all the stuff on the
left [ __ ] I can't see that girl there we
go
got it Wow your great job keep it up all
right oh you did it [ __ ]
what are you shooting okay big red
explosive barrels have you played a
video game before No or am I just
shooting so fast you can't see him
that's probably it
are we getting off you want uh yes can't
get off that sigh uh do you want to oh
my god all right machine gun ammo over
near me uh coming heads up crap it's a
part of pride okay and more back here
I'm gonna go ahead and [ __ ] got this
Molotov up are you laughing at hey
there's a lot of funny stuff to just
have in I got a better idea
here you cover me while I run Sanga I'm
up
something Star Wars meeting right here
I've pulled believer to picture two okay
so now do we want to go get back to the
boat there's birds coming we should just
hop on the boat okay there's birds
coming right for you all right are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yo knees stomp Birds
stab you thank you I just took machine
gun oh I don't need oh [ __ ] hissing -
he's grabbing nope it's not for you take
that okay okay
go joschwa right here guys we're
throwing dynamite it nothing idiots
ah low bridge for coming to a town low
bridge
everybody down because you always know
your neighbor you'll always know your
pal if you've ever traveled far on the
Erie Canal what um
upstate New York folklore uh let's kill
that guy folklore is not AB name the
thing oh no I was looking behind that a
guy who I didn't like got you oh I made
me feel good Oh what happened
you just pulp fiction like chest let's
go I'll go
oh [ __ ] I'm out of handgun ammo I should
keel um Jimmy D no I got it okay good
cuz I wait you should why I just I could
always use some heal I did I gave it to
you've got healed I did
I'm seals over here stop saying it wait
where you going I don't know there's all
this stuffing on the right I don't know
there's two switch left actually at this
part okay
oh I got shot over here oh man damn oh
I'm coming coming Claude man damn I'm on
the way I'm on the way I'm getting shot
yeah [ __ ] Gatling guns came out of
nowhere all right I'm in deeply injured
as well
yeah oh you died sorry that's all I
didn't know that Gatling guns gonna know
we're in this game well where do we hide
ready up nerd I have even had my little
vest on and everything all right so
that's I melee that's not pull it Oh
like not even a not even that hopeful
good job Sheva keep it up you ain't done
no bridge we're coming to us how however
oh right for ammo - hey we could really
use the Mikey
whoa a lot of that's nice
oh that should have shot you that should
have been friendly fire I think I'm
wasting exactly
maybe we need those later yeah probably
all right I'm gonna hopefully get rifle
ammo students I could take out those
Gatling guns
I have rifle ammo recommend would be
helpful for me
I'm out of almost everything
so what's up here then do you want to
split up or what uh do you any you have
right when I'm up can you give me some
oh no I don't have anything
oh no okay I I will shoot them just take
cover
no it's the wrong gun
Oh God all right I don't understand yeah
I don't have any ammo for anything I
could make a break all right I got it I
got it I know I'll get the other one in
the next time okay all right
sorry I didn't think about that oh I
think I'm gonna die sorry I'm stupid
oh [ __ ] there's rifle ammo right next to
my dad it's me anyway I don't like it
I'm gonna die I'm coming come over there
no no no no no all right I'm going back
to Derek's I'd try to shoot him okay I
got it
this is the one don't like get shot
though because I have ammo now I could
do something I'll kill him no I got it I
got it I got it I feel really good about
it this time did I get him I shot him
sweet all right now I'm going up
all right we're good
my side all right I'm working on it
Oh No
those guys gonna get on a Gatling gun Oh
God
screw you I'm like constantly getting
injured over here help
alright I got one
okay I'm trying to let me get some I
really could use no excited so I'm gonna
take the time to get em oh she got em oh
[ __ ] you come on let me go up here Oh
give me some English don't start I swear
oh I'll turn down game play Mary I'm not
kidding stop I'm full how am i full
Sheva Sheva hurry Sheva got hand game Oh
Sheva dude try figure out what I can't
you keep an egg you can see wants to
talk to it now the button tapping is
annoying what are you doing to me I'm
setting it with a lever this is so
boring for them to watch right now
people watching because I'm just up here
gathering supplies while you I can see
you what's going on oh I got a gem
alright because I explored I'm gonna get
the other one wait no hold on there's
stuff on this side too I think no yeah
yep mooo shotgun shells more shotgun
shells oh there is stuff up here you can
go get that barrel I'm going back there
side pull the lever pull the lever oh
sorry
now let's just play it play it soundless
it's handgun ammo my arch-nemesis I'm
not getting it get it for me I don't
have any room
I feel like you're being inconsistent
hypocritical yeah
all right wait come here
[Music]
thank you
oh I just got shot you got shot I did I
lost all my life just then who shot you
um I don't know back to the boat Oh a
lot of birds
holy [ __ ] tons them
oh right
well
back on the boat I have this like awning
and he can't get to me
whoa back on the boat oh that guy's
gotta hurt
put the fat but the photos about right I
can't believe I keep getting like
gravely injured
ya know like it's pretty severe oh
there's a red herb over here can I kind
of want you to get this
meet me on the boat
I'll protect you
there's more guys coming to vote like
right next to you
oh he's got a shovel he brought a shovel
to a gunfight
stab
how am i full hello wait
all right let's get in this boat your
chance okay right now you there's rifle
I'm on your side
dammit I just saw it dang looks like ya
cuz you'll always know your neighbor
you'll always know your pal back to the
swamp
[Music]
there's like no keys or anything in this
you know yeah like the iconic scorpion
key and whatever
yeah I know that was you nice shaver
would have only needed one bullet hello
these guys back he needs more teeth your
masters one more time what we want you
alright
Oh
that thing for a minute black yes forget
it the mind eraser yeah don't you two
just are y'all ready you making me look
bad
who do you think of this entire
operation of the ground grease it's like
this doesn't pump itself you know yet
everyone looks down on me
don't do it alright the virus
[Music]
probably do
[Music]
beyond anything you can ever hope to
become I've made a huge mistake
[Music]
I am now
buried underwater and octopus man
brainiac doctoral
wait that him mm-hmm grew really fast
Home Edition
it's like guys named ty that hosts
extreme makeover I don't you know what I
don't know if I've seen one episode of
extreme makeover what was his name type
type Henning let's get on with machine
down what Danna yep for you
Oh Alps one on each go down and what am
I shoot that yellow growing 300 shoot
rockets
wait I she with tentacles or yes now
there's like parts in the middle of it
oh right the weak point for massive
damage right shoots rockets oh look I
have that problem
such a strange boss by all this thing up
front Oh like
action for sure but not [ __ ] I'm almost
dead action for sure but not a lot of
like you should heal up
hi I can't oh he's behind us was that
not like a maze oh I have the wrong [ __ ]
[Music]
oh listen he may or may not have hit me
I got it I'm back left side other side
go to that rocket one on the corner the
oh this one got it
show yourself
rock
exercise Red Square
[ __ ] me I like definitely it's odd that
time I was ready I got to leave the shop
more here
all right good not going well for me
he's in front now I know he's in the
other side
Oh tentacles
huh
shoot his Adam's apple
how can you tell if it's a boy
cuz her Adam's apple was as big as her
balls what oh yeah imma shake a quick
wasting time I'm coming
it was just this like gross little uvula
yeah just like hanging out
you shoot him I'll shoot tentacles our
get ready to not know what bullsh
exemple you ready to dodge though I did
dodge I don't think I know how to dodge
shoot em shoot em shoot em
die you man baby you're a Dada just
mouthing what I protect see ya oh no I
was not the turret so I think that's
what's happening to me
you have to get completely off the
turret and then hit the button
senticles
think I did it
yeah
oh I thought we died
I feel like kinky did that dude like
basically like get rid of him I feel you
didn't need to know like there's like a
there's like a water monster hanging out
now he was like I'm just gonna give her
this dude
cuz he's gross annoying this bacilli
yeah
answer me and he says project you say
yeah while you two are just some 50 Cal
rounds in the void ass changing and
you're completely oblivious to it what's
changing what are you talking about
it's the good in photos project is that
it ruh-roh Boros is about to change
everything we've ever
see your Chris that's so funny
how do you know about me all your
answers a way to head Chris in that cave
if he can survive long enough to get
them I feel like this was written by
someone where they were like don't give
any details away because don't know what
you're talking about so just write stuff
like you'll find out soon enough
[Music]
bastard now what we keep going to the
cave you not freaking hear him sweet a
really good photo of him uh dude that
honestly is me on the left that was so
bad
bee I got my first B but B student shut
the shooting well sell some [ __ ] or
anything to sell I got that one everyone
I have this ring stuff to buy don't buy
it at a high price
[ __ ] the new shotguns here I'm gonna get
that I think rocket launcher we're gonna
get that shotgun rocket Lanza do you
want um a melee pack that you wear
because I have to I really think you
should consider for a second school this
melee Bacchus oh I just get end up
selling it for $1,000 and taking $9,000
loss then somes got a better shot gun
looks nice it's like why would you
upgrade your shotgun if you're going to
get a better shotgun
do you ever need a rocket launcher um I
would not recommend getting that what
about another me later
nope that joke to each their own
yeah sweet sweet wait I want to buy a
wait note I want to organize and then do
I like select this an upgraded right
that's how I do it
I've really enjoyed my shotgun what's
your firepower for your shotgun I just
want to know mm damn
I can go much higher than this 372 400 I
know this is it for me look this is my
last upgrade I should just buy a new
shotgun that makes me mad though
[ __ ] you you can just uh pick that one
and roll that no that's as high as it
upgrades like I'm done though that's why
I'm mad cuz I I spent a lot of money
upgrading it and for what for what is
this the new shotgun this guy yep the m3
yeah I'm gonna buy it and what's up I
want this
um and then I will put this here and
then I will put this
yeah so it I did sell it sweet job just
before you forget yeah put your shopping
in the bottom slot so you can just press
down to switch to it right we go for a
little while longer make it a stir it we
owe them we didn't do one last year last
week and then rifle ammo can I like yeah
nice can I combine this with my other
one great move can combine two your
shotgun shells oh yeah
then rifle yeah right and then I'll take
this heel all right I'm ready
Rocket Man
[Music]
cabins where the answers to all my
questions are in the caves that's what
I've been told that in honesty was up
here alone down here as long as she was
talking about that's both the woman used
to get away nice she's smart
so she's pretty cool character yeah yes
like I'm one Chris about Jill
but the udo bulldoze project is wet I
guess what I mean is is like I guess
there's nothing I can do to stuff games
fairly older and for a lot of action
with Drew or like scary games back in
the day women didn't have like the
always the best roles trying she's
pretty pretty good she's smart
I like Jill in the first game yeah
Jill's Jill is actually rock-solid she's
got it going on
oh he's dead
where did he go did he say to take care
of some stuff because that means that he
is super gonna kill us
South African decision do you think she
could be connected to Irving damn your
health is low I know I liked Adnan as a
connection I have a full heal should I
say that but if we keep going well bound
to find out true let's move
that's fine forgot this place looks nice
this looks like the bring you start off
in Skyrim Oh
Spidey's crap Jesus
jump up
you uh you say Oh cuz it was handgun
Emma yeah growth spider back here
he's like following you you gotta
some stuff back here before we need to
go up I don't know
great thing up there oh there's some pot
can you heal up you're making me nervous
well I wanted you to be here to share
the moment Oh
to kill me to magic yes it's far less
sentiment about you
holy [ __ ] spider army just popped up out
of the ground
where are you down come on I'll come up
here yeah oh yeah I see them all right
I'll protect you do they take the ladder
do there are more coming no I don't
let's just keep going
wait I just wanna make sure they don't
come up it's not the ladder to them yeah
that'd be hard Jimmy Jimmy to helium
that makes holy [ __ ] they're a lot lots
of spiders grenades would be great right
now um I have a grenade there's one
right next to you
oh that one's not that [ __ ] I'm coming
coming grab him
hand gun
stay on the grounds I'm just shooting
rifle back here I can't pick up okay I'm
coming I will go back and get it
ah what I was debating if I should heal
or not
no wait is it jewelry oh look at jewel
jewel do you hear that someone vacuuming
outside this room possible do that or
somebody's pumping in something toxic
gas I'm toxic gas into this room
actually escape from that gas met judge
out and mass mass aah oh [ __ ] I forgot
about these parts catacombs some sort
yeah oh look at that that's nice
there is puzzle Shin this man it's
alright it'll be fun
this kind of looks like Tomb Raider
that's nice it does and I've been
wanting to replay rise the Tomb Raider
on ps4 Xbox one oh really that's my
number two game 2000 selected what it
was up there for me that's for sure I
was gonna be shooting hard as hell
what's your number one so far this year
[ __ ] it was Zelda but the more I play
like pray cuz I love pray first 105 it's
really great but then I still to finish
near neo what remains of Edith Finch
outlast 2 I want to replay present evil
7 @ vr you need to play outlast 2 [ __ ]
more injustice I really like injustice
I'm not typically fighting oh yeah I
heard you you said you liked it yeah
it's got some like it's got RPG
mechanics that are hooking me and I
suspect it'll be a fighting game that a
lot of non fighting game fans start to
pick up cool my game of the year so far
is Zelda yeah we hit the jackpot here
this guy must have turned into money
when he died spider normal-size [ __ ]
that's probably one of their bigger ones
cousins that was like his baby
they're gonna come after you now oh I
triggered us and think we got everything
oh wow those are some strong zombies but
oh oh do we get split up yeah crash
crash dude I can see your biceps from
here of course you can check them out oh
you're flexing check them out wait a
minute hold on wait a minute you want to
see them okay so you're flexing wait
Chris flex for me hey let me do do nice
360 for me yeah wait no it'll be better
the pistol hey you get your damn hands
off her
looking good wait a minute wait a minute
zoom in on it and I know you know what I
mean by it
hey man hey donk
don't wait Craig wait a minute
I mean let me what are you looking at
that laser on my wiener no it's on my
head wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
I'll put it on your head you know I mean
oh my god bro you shoot me no where am I
supposed to go I can't go anywhere so I
can jump down though sick um hey I just
jumped down you're on your own
you should he'll probably movie I said
go back to the dude with the Spears
oh I need your help why [ __ ] I'm dying
stop [ __ ] please huh sorry I didn't do
this fear really rocked okay [ __ ] hmm
your butt still looks good even a death
she was set hot I'm sorry it's an open
casket funeral and her she's laying butt
up some people remember um my fault I'll
do better this time no it's I was
supposed to cover you and I was getting
gold so I think we're both to blame here
I wonder if you have you have to be the
one the other side oh let's give this
touchpad that [ __ ] all right yep I guess
so
sweet so yeah do your thing and then
I'll drop down right oh is that what um
is that what does it mean jumping down
triggers a yeah I believe okay it's cuz
there's there's all this money over here
and then I think take your time getting
this stuff there's a pot well I need you
for it so that's why you died no I just
need to climb up whoa there's a guy in
here yeah they're like waiting to ambush
maybe you don't need to cover me just
dude
I'll go down chick I got stabbed should
heal I forgot to working on it
damnit
are you dead no look I might be [ __ ]
to you throw scare be [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright there's a rotten egg over here
don't really be buried are you sure damn
I have no health all right wait I'm
coming I'm gonna cover you you're fine I
cover you [ __ ] Spears really Rock oh
damn it just dude over there I'm not
doing a very good job of coming I'm good
oh I got this guy
don't you worry the green herbs I'm
gonna use this from now sweet all right
good
I'm lieutenant dang you got no head all
right so the mummy in the stock office
Mays place was a burial ground great I
wasn't reading that before so I was too
scared and then there's a green herb
over here and there's an egg over here
and I can't take either of them oh [ __ ]
are you in trouble
oh [ __ ]
I got
stab stab
so there is um I'm [ __ ] I use that
cleaner so wait can I give something to
you or no ye can now yes what are you
trying to give to me um if I give you
this grenade I can pick up a red and get
it and combine them into a red and a
green okay what if you actually pulled
the pin before you gives me hey what
give me a live grenade okay cool
another vote thank you another treasure
chest thing money money money
honey more money more problems
mmm I don't think that that is true like
I you know they made worse let's go over
here what was it a lover that you had to
do
so there's ah it's gone there's a green
at urban here and then there was a
rotten egg but I couldn't pick it up it
wasn't egg and then there's another one
over here
Spyder
get [ __ ] Oh No
Oh
labyrinth with a treasure chest over
there all right let me oh there's that
there's an herb and a and an aid a
handful too
can I not give things to you temporarily
or no allow me
that guy behind us with the torches
right next to you
prep try to sneak on me dinya take that
cuz I was gonna say um just so we don't
lose them what if like you have a green
herb I'm gonna use a green herb come
here
alright I'm gonna use this come here
[ __ ] egg I'm full oh go down that way
out that door just ready you can take
that right all right do you want to open
this
I'm nervous about these chests um just
get ready for like QuickTime events or
something it's a ruby I got it emerald
that's gonna be a sapphire I'm calling
it over this way
wait oh I'm full I bet wait wait wait
stay right there stay right there don't
move okay good good
wait did again a little weather this up
right okay okay send them out with a
rifle first crossbowmen
[ __ ] dead oops
show yourself
anymore I don't care I'm going I will
continue to cover you watching my six
that's all you're not I was just
watching my sex I missed I got it I got
you hit it with the shoes are calling
you good yeah a lot of stuff down hey
wait a minute
this is like a boss thing I think I
think about the trigger something I feel
like you're gonna trigger something
let me get as much as I can before that
happens stay up there that might be
there's a lot of stuff down there pick
up all the stuff on it
hey wait there's a grenade behind you
are you have room for all this [ __ ] I
already have grenades
ah [ __ ] I can't do anything about
oh [ __ ] look at happening oh my god run
shava back sitting up here what is this
what is this do
oh I need you to get down here why it's
dangerous down there she needs my help
you on his lever yeah your biceps I'll
be right there babe
what are we doing probably opening that
door then we have the dodge these giant
flaming
bocce balls well I want some of these
items yeah I don't know if it's worth
taking the damage to get there we can
try I just I just won't take any damage
my tactic is to just not take any damage
Chrissa sir for now do those explode for
a while I believe so yeah
[ __ ] oh oh all right I touched one just
like bowling except we're the pin
Tom Pitt in fact no wait yeah what did
that did we not do that I think it went
back off base
she says all right we got to go back
turn it again but this time for real
[Music]
shut
Oh
okay I got decent money man one
contraption is this that's full here go
go it's stupid go go go go go oh it
go go go go go go go oh oh I saw you
[ __ ] get rocked oh wait
Father's hand there's something back
here Oh get there
whatever that hole on hand got ammo what
is it
hyung got my own ham I guess we can get
my mouse for it then
all right well gobble wah wah yeah I
guess let's go
I've got fully off everything unless you
have room for handgun ammo yeah what
about it everyone go ride oh we're stuck
oh that looks dangerous up on it doing a
[ __ ] dare you
okay there dump
Oh quick time that's probably uh
good thing that is a pretty impressive
jump they're doing
just a pull-up do a pull-up hmm
do a backflip he weighs like nine nine
tons did you see how they [ __ ] did it
again
Swan doe they jumped over each other
let's blow this the shadows don't make
sense there's no light above us
that's the over-analytical that's our
lighting as well five Preciosa
is a well-made they're not commenting on
like what is this place
they're just taking it right yeah like
they have the Last Guardian there's no
commentary on like how ridiculous this
is
wait-wait-wait-wait over down there yet
wait I might be triggered over this way
actually it's another arena this is what
resonable games are at their best when
they give you just open like sandbox
area and then let you kind of run around
and survive and abate people like for
village Reggio for right like decide how
you want to deal with this evil with the
evil within specimens those who don't
know it was also directed by Shinji
Mikami who started resin evil has a
couple seconds like that that's the best
part Akane the rest of the game I don't
love yeah I liked the evil with them I
liked the first there's 15 chapters I
like ten of them the last five are awful
I thought I thought doing I don't know
this is a huge area and there's oh I
found a book I found a gun you should
make room for that maybe use that
greener about us your singular greener
okay do you want to come over here if
have you been upgrading your mp5
no okay sweet did it come with granades
dad I came with 12 I can't take this
came with granades was berry call it
mello Yello I think oh I see with you
come over where I am now alright or did
it suck except to do the green Buddha
yeah I gotta get to the other side to
pull the other way do not start do not
press circle on that yet please please
don't go your side
and I have that like that baby group
vibe to me don't I I do not see no
trailer is it good oh [ __ ] there's a
first date right here oh good
we're like tonight you're up I don't
really like tend to like any DC Marvel
movies but that one's like reasonably
entertaining I drop these two flash
bangs for this first day spray probably
I have a full heal sorry I got some you
hope you have an egg no that's not going
anywhere all right I'm here finally do
it
what happens if I pull it without you
would just be Sheva oh I I thought it
like killed you or something no I just
didn't want him to be annoying Oh
impressive structure that they've built
whoever they are
oh no probably a faster you go this way
they're gonna be enemies now what makes
you say that
oh [ __ ] no I can't go this way it's
closed off now hold on a second with
them so I guess you could say that out
there yet that's the long way it's the
impossible right
come on come on shovel
there are when you got really mad you
don't get heads they killed you on
accident
I don't recall oh I remember
infamous drawbridge incident of April
2017 this is actually the first time I
would say that I'm like really impressed
with like a design of an area yeah this
is really nice
oh I hear dudes
they have
got a rifles men even right now is
impossible I love that guy with like to
fire wands so I can't see like a dude up
to powers
so I have that um I I have that grenade
should I use it the grenade thing
grenade or not behind you
sweet
alright you're raking it in
I didn't give their time [ __ ] this guy
Hey I got him for you friendly fire
we should get off this bridge we're
sitting ducks Oh
watch out behind us press I click the
lipstick twice when you can I don't know
what that's a small [ __ ] my talent
stomp guys are dropping anything
give me the drops going down town
all right we're getting there pretty
sure we are here
where we go now back down I guess
I think yet maybe I'm here to this
monkey guess so
are they monkey way there's a treasure
chest over here I I think they're
supposed to be like witch doctors if
shrunken heads to him
the Black Panther flash round oh grenade
rounds over here if you want him flash
grenades I don't know maybe I should be
using my grenades cuz I can't take these
oh I see there's only one here so I
think we have to go down for the other
one yeah the other I can't take these
don't worry about it are you sure yeah
uh we gotta go down to them and actually
you you go down the stairs and I'll wait
up here with this one changed oh yeah I
can't take it I don't have any room well
Fassett let's go well I just feel bad
that was a lot are we going to this
monkey did we determine if they were
monkeys which doctor oh I said go down
all right you step here the other chain
is down I was like go for now though
Mary I'm not kidding you might you're
gonna cover me I don't know if that's
chair I don't know where you are I see
is my goal in the night one huh yeah so
they're actually they're coming toward
you
they're coming they're right next to you
there's about to drop down on top of you
[ __ ] away
spiders oh [ __ ] yes
[Applause]
god
oh stop stop stop
how are you doing good how are you okay
a lot of guys down here [ __ ] no I'm not
sorry
ah she'll be tonight probably will not
get it in time
[ __ ] I [ __ ] up so I don't know how to
get to you I was dumb and cried got the
best of me as did fired maybe I should
go down this time cuz I have all those
grenades you want to hear I have that
grenade gun I got it ready up boom
oh yeah fool all right so what I'll do
is I'll go downstairs and I'll use my
new found grenade guns
when did you trigger all the bad guys I
know okay
Oh
they come from the where you came from
as well battle-ax
oh I missed
but
I have this cool grenade gun and I am
not using it
pretty good okay
put fire on me that's all right I'm
still doing okay not doing great but I'm
doing okay not many guys up here try to
go go to the other side the ring second
Oh enemies go too late to your right
oh my god you're good you're good you're
good
Oh No
Hey I got it again
don't you run away spider behind you aah
Oh God I'm empty hold on hon hon next to
you dude next year and I'm empty I'm
bottom rifle and in me uh whistling
that's all you from there on out pretty
much sorry to say I got grenades I can
throw I guess but you seem to have it
under control there's one more spider
behind you
stop moving I used all my shotgun job
she's got more
all right I'll pick up this handgun amma
for you all right do you wanna pull this
corridor whatever ya
stairs mom I guess that opened up stuff
for me yeah wait where we never got that
treasure chest after that fence oh I
mean it's right here but it's just
classroom it is should have been
grenades yeah flash rounds for your name
Walter um can you come here we still
separated um I think I can't be there
cuz there's um
stuff I want to give you so I can get ya
proximity mine hi
take this church do you want that
shotgun oh yeah I can't take all right
give me something can you give me your
can you give me a rifle ammo honestly
I'm out like all I know no I think
anyone everyone take your perhaps any
money I can't in full
nor doubt either ways to pull it for
that um we're going where are we going
upstairs or is that where you came from
no going yeah I guess we are going up
according to the map
am I reading them a fright or no it's
hard to tell I don't know what where
you're supposed to be at vertically
alright so you said it was just flash
grenades bunch of dicks grenade rounds
are way better
I gotta not pay attention to what that
opened up I just saw that stairs became
not stairs this is so frustrating for
people watching that saw what it did uh
really find it I'm just gonna keep going
in circle back toward this red do it
says red dude over here I see this guy
apoll0 downstairs told our to find me
okay
and then right
nope nope
yeah
okay we're getting there stairs
all right we got out sweet dust feel
like [ __ ] Tomb Raider right now oh
that's like out of nowhere flash around
I'll be great I just Renee we fought one
of these dudes all right these things
[ __ ]
you knew me a chance press the wrong
button kill me Mary I'm sorry I can't
get to you not even trying you're just
standing watching it murder me
well I couldn't get to you he was too
far didn't really try too hard to go
around him hmm
you just you're just trying to make me
look bad fine hey hey it's gonna be
really fun next time you need help gonna
be awesome so awesome
Oh for god sake it's gonna be so sweet
come on okay come on
approximately I'll you just go for the
stairs eating even dodge it yeah I just
press the wrong but my son just stupid
quick time
[Music]
yes I can
he died behind coffin stairs stairs
oh [ __ ] run I think
yes keep running let me check killers
get to the top
what do we look died stone press X a lot
I'm pretty sure we different one
obviously not enough that room hold on
hold on one cut that
go-go-go
I could be wrong we have to kill him
before you try this one sport let's try
one more time
[Music]
you could also lay down a proximity mind
that's what I was thinking I don't know
if I want to stop take it out now
what okay I definitely hit X so did I
all right well I think dodge maybe let's
just [ __ ] kill him so I don't get on
to the stairs and then shoot him all
right
that's fine I'm fine with that no don't
you want to shoot the back part of him
oh yeah maybe we should do it down here
then
that's the dodge run to get behind it
every time I guess
Oh [ __ ] live
I start
you
Oh
get on the ground
you
Wow nice well that was all my grenades
but that's nice I'm not complaining give
me your soul gem Knievel's that it can
evil joke yeah yeah yes I have so many
running gags and I forget what your only
guy has like no pallidus soul gem and I
took it give me your phone do you
hey you you there do you have souls I'll
trade you for the soul gem delicious
soul
I would like to grill your soul and
maybe marinated several days growth all
right sweet it's probably a good spot to
end at 90-minute episode see what
happens next
we got a little longer Oh Oh aah help me
not talk about his code Veronica got an
L for PS go drown it goes on ps4 now
hood that makes more sense to play it
now mmm we still should do number titles
oh I forgot about this girl Axela quite
a hottie for now you know I was
surprised las Plagas was such a success
success that's black ass first that I
had my doubts retinol for it and now
Roberto says complete who do you think
the composition of try cell is secured
uh someone from umbrella I have my eyes
sit on some
much bigger ah you'll be needing a
partner right someone suitable to join
you in your new work
I believe I've proven onward yeah
go lower
Wesker he's such a bad guy
and an iceberg there's your old friend
Chris Redfield has come to pay a visit
do I sense concern the plan is in its
final stages that will not tolerate
delays said tolerate like a British
person but the rest of the sentences
American accent on my way bird girl who
is who is that girl
XLR the bird girl uh axela what's her
name axela
I guess although I don't remember seeing
her ever before Oswald Spencer
who's to become a god is my I believe I
should thank you steps as well
Oswald how guys evil mmm-hmm sweet dolls
make sure it saves damn another be
accuracy I got a break in the game
touchpad probably that's bad uh we're
getting towards I don't how many
chapters I don't know forgot I don't
this games I'm gonna go in spy it's not
as long as four and it's not as long as
six six is a twenty eight hours oh my
god but six is not a good game at all
it's actually pretty bad but it'll be
fun to stream alright what is so stupid
at some part but it just is kind of uh
so one thing that resin will four and
five mainly for do well is that there's
a lot of feedback when you shoot the
zombies like you can shoot him the lag
and they'll stumble and then you can
like wound them there it's all about
where you're shooting them uh where's
Evil six doesn't have that so that's why
I'm not always too excited for that
you can't shoot people in the legs you
can but there's not as much like
reaction to your shots and it gets
really boring just to shoot zombies I
feel like that the haircut really badly
really guys all right sweet shower - I
don't know why I'm still talking uh
sweet we will be back next week - 90
minutes they're close I need new clothes
and a haircut and a tan anything else
wrong with me Mary I'm ending the
episode better teeth oh my gosh I'm
actually pretty sensitive on my teeth so
thanks I'm going to go home